[Music]
your fans are absolutely incredible they
are so loyal Brian you see that you got
one fan letter that really stood out of
all the fan land I was we were talking
about that I said I'm gonna bring this
fan letter with me can I read it - yes
you may all right so this spent this is
an honest goodness fan letter came to me
it says dear Bryan Cranston let me
preface this letter by saying I have a
master's degree in psychology and I have
never been diagnosed with any psychotic
disorder you know when a when a letter
starts out with I have never been
diagnosed with any psychotic no one's
caught me I am writing to you because I
have been holed up in my apartment for
two days and nights watching all seasons
of your show I am in love with it all
after I was done with all the episodes I
watched some interviews and what this is
all amounted to is that right now I am
fantasizing about having sex with Aaron
Paul
yes
[Applause]
and and for you to be there watching
it's a true yeah what are you doing in
heaven Ariane says I am not sure what
your role would be but I think I want
you there he's giving you some leeway to
you you figure it out you say he's
giving me some leeway here she says she
was a whole time
you you pictured a letter however you
want often Trudeau Iowa
laughing she is come on
it would be a good time now I have to
bring this up there are so many finale
theories there's actually a theory for
the finale that waltz in the witness
protection program he gets a new family
and he changes his name to how and it's
the prequel to Malcolm in the Middle
that was a genius that's and then that
whole series run and that series runs
but it already ran so how do we don't
you understand yeah time doesn't mean
anything
speaking of the last episode I none of
us we don't want to know anything but it
but what I do have what I heard about
two hours ago was that you read the two
of you read the last episode together
yes before you shot it you sat together
and you read it is that right yes we
would there's a really wonderful
documentary that two-hour documentary
that's going to be in the final
compilation of DVDs and it's really
in-depth and we thought it would be a
fun idea for Erin and I to read it cold
out loud in this documentary so we read
this without knowing what was going to
happen and then they intercut that
earlier with with vince gilligan writing
the last episode it was a it was a fun
thing and was that must have been very
powerful when you got towards the end it
was a very emotional experience I think
i'ma fur for us for sure I mean when he
said when he read out loud end of series
there was probably a good 10 15 seconds
or just just sitting quietly away wow
we're never going to read another first
episode again it's over yeah thanks for
bringing that up
I can't think of a better time to go to
commercial on that
and that huge laughs we'll be right back